So Leute, noch mal ganz schnell am Start.
Ich habe mir gedacht, komm jetzt noch die letzte Stunde, mach es einfach mal streamern.
Wahrscheinlich keiner da, also noch keiner da, denke ich mal, oder?
Test, Test, jemand schon am Start.
So quasi das Gegenstück zum Abo-Box-Camper von früher auf YouTube.
Ah, yes, exzellent, exzellent.
So, jetzt muss ich erst mal kurz die Emotes noch eine Runde kleiner machen.
Eine Runde den Chat Gachi-Bassen, solange er noch nicht da ist.
So, gut, passt, wunderbar.
Ja, Leute, also ich habe für diese Stunde jetzt, wo ich on bin, vielleicht ein paar Minuten länger, müssen wir mal gucken.
Ich habe nichts Großartiges mir ausgedacht, aber erst mal muss Twitch checken, dass der Stream online ist.
Jetzt hat es Twitch angeblich kapiert.
Wenn man Twitch glaubt, sind schon 13 Leute da, exzellent, Leute.
Exquisite.
Ah, jetzt kommen die ersten Leute hier an den Start, ich sehe es schon.
Ja, du bist erster, wobei laut Zuschauerzahlen bist du nicht erster, aber du bist definitiv erster, der was im Chat schreibt.
YouTube-Krankheit, ja.
Du hast gesagt, was hast du gesagt?
Lass ich heute noch mal on kommen.
Keckweight.
Luxemburg, exzellent.
Da gibt es Steuern von Amazon, habe ich gehört.
Oder besser gesagt, es gibt Deutschland.
Es gibt dort relativ wenige Steuern von Amazon, wobei, wobei, Moment, sind die da überhaupt noch?
Ist Amazon da überhaupt noch?
Haben die nicht, haben die nicht umgesourced oder was auch immer?
Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, früher war, Amazon war Luxemburg immer.
Neuseeland ist bester Land für reiche Menschen, das mag sein, aber dafür, ich gelte eventuell am Hand des Durchschnitts irgendwie als reich.
Aber erstens fühle ich mich nicht reich.
Und zweitens bin ich für Neuseeland definitiv nicht reich genug.
Das ist eigentlich der Witz, ab was man mittlerweile schon als reich gilt, ne.
Ich hab, für mich ist jemand reich, der irgendwie drei goldene BMWs hat oder so.
Wobei ich mir, selbst wenn ich das Geld hätte, keinen goldenen BMW kaufen würde, aber ihr wisst, was ich meine.
Kenyon ist auch am Start, nice.
Google kommt jetzt auch.
Tja, ja, würde ich auch so machen.
Also wenn ich so viel Kohle hätte, dann würde, dann würde ich auch nach Luxemburg gehen.
Wer ist eigentlich so in Madrid?
Dera oder wo unge, ist da so ein Steuersatz?
Kein Schimmer.
Wahrscheinlich auch ganz okay.
Ja, na klar, na klar, aber es geht mir auf den Sack, dass ich das mache.
Achso, du meinst, du meinst in Luxemburg, ja, in Luxemburg Spitzensteuersatz, weiß ich was.
Was ist der Spitzensteuersatz in Luxemburg für Leute wie Amazon?
4,5 Prozent?
Keine Ahnung.
Echt, ist der jetzt, ist der jetzt auf Neuseeland?
War der nicht in Australien?
Nee, Moment.
Der war auf Neuseeland und die wollten, die sollten irgendwie ausliefern an die USA.
Was ist denn da eigentlich rausgekommen?
Was ist da eigentlich rausgekommen?
Wo ist der denn?
Da war aber Knossi im Stream.
Ja gut, das ist jetzt kein unbedingt große Auszeichnung, finde ich, aber kann man sich drüber streiten.
Wo ist der denn jetzt?
Was macht der denn jetzt gerade?
Ah ja, Berufung, Berufung.
Auslieferung.
Achso.
Ganz im Ernst, ich würde auch an kein Land ausliefern, was irgendwelche komischen Gefangenen, halboffiziellen Gefangenenlager hat.
Aber, Kekona hat halt was zu sagen.
Der hat doch noch ein paar Megamillionen.
Ja, ich hoffe es mal für ihn, weil das braucht er auch.
Der investiert auch in Krypto, ja, gut, macht, glaube ich, aktuell irgendwie jeder mit, mit Huge, Huge Stonks.
Eier, ja.
Also, Leute, ähm, wie gesagt, ich bin bloß noch eine Stunde, ich bin bloß noch eine Stunde am Start.
Äh, wisst ihr, wisst ihr, was ich gemacht habe, bevor ich ongekommen bin?
Ich habe endlich meine Waage, meine Waage an meinen Home Assistant angeschlossen.
Aber das zeige ich euch jetzt nicht.
Ich habe die, ich habe die Waage an mein Smart Home angeschlossen, dass ich weiß immer, wie, wie fett ich bin und ob das rauf oder runter geht.
Ich habe hier so ein Ding hier.
Ich mache mal, wisst ihr was, Leute?
Ich mache mal die.
Ich mache mal die VM an.
Es surft sich einfach angenehmer in der VM unter Linux.
Bei, ach ja, wo wir gerade, wo wir gerade dabei sind, VM und Linux.
Kriegt jemand von euch oder hat jemand von euch auch diese, die Scam, die, diese Scam-E-Mails bekommen mit ihr Paket ist da aus dem Facebook-Leak?
Also, ich habe eine gekriegt, aber habe ich euch ja schon erzählt vor, keine Ahnung, zwei Wochen oder so ist das schon her.
Hast du über 30 PMI, da kannst du dich früher, ne, ich, ich, ich kann mich leider.
Ne, ne, ich glaube.
30 reicht nicht.
Ich glaube, 30 reicht nicht.
Ich habe nachgeguckt.
Also, ich bin noch nicht fett genug, um mich früher impfen zu lassen.
Das hatte ich nachgeguckt.
Das habe ich euch auch mal erzählt vor, glaube ich, einem Monat oder so.
Genau, 40er-BMI braucht man.
So war es.
Genau, und ich bin nicht dick genug gewesen.
Es gibt jetzt also nur zwei Möglichkeiten.
Entweder ich warte auf einen normalen Impftermin oder ich nehme jetzt einfach irgendwie nochmal so zu, dass ich 40 plus BMI habe.
30 ist Prio 3.
Na gut, Prio 3 ist quasi alle anderen.
Das ist 80, 70 und dann der Rest quasi.
Wie dick bist du?
Ja, da hättest du dabei sein müssen im Stream, als wir die Waage eingerichtet haben.
Naja, sag mal so, ich bin auf jeden Fall nicht der Schlankste.
Cute, Pepo, fett.
Äh, so, was soll ich jetzt sagen?
Ich habe ja dieses Teil hier.
Miescale, ich habe eine 2er.
Kurze Frage, weil ich gerade dran bin.
Ich scrolle mal kurz auf den Chat rüber.
Schon Erfahrung mit Docker und IPv6 machen?
Nö.
Muss man da irgendwas beachten, wenn man nur die nur...
Nein, ich habe keine Ahnung.
Habe ich noch nie.
Noch nie ausprobiert, noch nie bewusst.
Aber nachdem IPv6 quasi eh immer standardmäßig an ist mittlerweile,
werde ich wahrscheinlich Docker auch schon über IPv6 gemacht haben, ohne dass ich es weiß.
Ja, ja, die geht ohne Internet.
Das ist ja gerade Sinn und Zweck der Sache gewesen.
Also ich habe dieses Teil hier als Waage.
Für Pepo Fettstells.
So sieht das aus.
Ist sogar tatsächlich relativ günstig.
Also, so sieht das Ding aus.
Hallo?
Möchtet ihr da draufklicken?
Okay, da ist genau an der richtigen Stelle platziert.
Ja, so sieht das Teil aus.
Und das Nice ist, das hat, man sieht es ja sicher, hier oben ist...
Das ist ja total beknackt gemacht.
Also hier oben ist die eigentliche Anzeige, wie viel man wiegt.
Der Friseur, klar, der streamt auch öfters.
Hier oben ist die Anzeige, wie viel man wiegt.
Und das Ganze geht ohne Internet.
Das überträgt über Bluetooth.
Und ich habe das jetzt eingerichtet, dass ich da quasi der gleiche...
Der Coolchamp.
Der, der die Kühlschranktemperatur ausliest, der liest jetzt auch das Ding aus.
Das habe ich jetzt hinten auf dem Klo stehen.
Ich habe da hinten auf dem Klo...
Moment, Moment.
Ich habe ja schon zu allem irgendwie Video gemacht.
Ich kann euch das ja alles zeigen.
Easy as fuck.
So, Max, zeig da...
Gehst du fort?
Wie fett ist die Katze?
Ja, die wiegt auch...
Die wiegt auch ein bisschen mehr, aber es geht so.
So, Moment.
Ich muss warten, bis ich die Absenkautomatik zumache.
Moment, Moment.
Ich muss das Klo schließen.
Irgendwann mache ich das Klo zu.
Moment, habe ich das Klo am Anfang...
Moment, mache ich das Klo nie zu im Video?
Can't wait.
Ich mache das Klo nie zu.
Ja, weil ich habe das Ding...
Guck mal, Leute.
Hier unten ist eine...
Ups.
Strahler auf Maximum.
Ja, klar.
Ja.
In your face strahlen.
So.
Hier hinten ist eine Steckdose.
Ich habe hier hinten so ein spritzwasserdichtes 90 Cent Gehäuse hingelegt.
Mit einem...
Mit einem Controller.
Hängt hier unten an der Steckdose.
Und macht Empfang für die Waage und für die Miflora-Sensors.
Und der wird auch noch Empfang machen für diesen...
Für das Ding, das was wir letztens geflasht haben im Stream.
Für das Teil, das haben wir auch geflasht.
Das ist so ein Thermometer an der Wand.
Und dann kann ich aus dem Bad übertragen lassen.
Temperatur, Luftfeuchtigkeit.
Ich kann damit dann quasi auch die...
Die...
Die Heizungssteuern.
Also mit dem Regler, der an der Heizung dran ist, kann ich dann anhand von Temperatur und Luftfeuchtigkeit,
also anhand von Temperatur, das einrichten.
Also je nachdem.
Also sprich, ich kann dann beispielsweise sagen, es ist ein Wochentag.
Ich muss auf die Arbeit fahren.
Es ist nach 6.30 Uhr.
Oder besser gesagt, es ist nach 5.45 Uhr, je nachdem wann ich fahre.
Und dann geht schon mal die Heizung an und sowas.
Das ist eigentlich richtig nice.
Ja, mit den...
Ob ich auf dem Klo bin, kacken kann man damit leider nicht kontrollieren.
Aber das ist äußerst, äußerst nice.
Siehste?
Und jetzt kriege ich den ganzen Krams direkt live in mein Home Assistant gestelzt.
Ohne Flaschen.
Ja, es hat aber Vorteil, das Zeug zu flashen.
Erstens, also erstmal muss man sagen, das zu flashen ist total einfach.
Haben wir letztens im Stream gemacht.
Stream habe ich gelöscht.
Ich habe mir überlegt, ich lösche diese...
Ich lösche diese ganzen Hackerman-Streams.
Erstens, weil ich nicht weiß,
ob Twitch mal den YouTube macht und Hacker-Kram irgendwie bannt.
Weiß man ja nie.
Und das Zweite ist, weil es immer mal sein kann,
dass ich da aus Versehen, ohne dass ich es mitkriege,
irgendwelche Mac-Adressen und sowas leake.
Und das muss ich ja nicht unbedingt mehr in der Welt rumposaunen,
als es eh schon ist, ja.
Sind die im Archiv?
Nein, das ist nicht im Archiv.
Deswegen, die sollen auch nicht ins Archiv.
Weil, wie gesagt, falls ich da irgendwelche Dinge aus Versehen mal leake,
ohne dass ich es selbst merke,
dann, äh, ja.
Streams, die online sind, sind nicht im Archiv.
Streams, die länger online sind als ein Tag,
also wenn ich mir da sicher bin, dass ich nichts aus Versehen gezeigt habe,
wenn ich irgendwie beispielsweise ein paar Sachen flashe,
ohne dass ich mal ein Raspberry Pi-Netzwerk-Scan gemacht oder sowas,
äh, dann lasse ich die drin,
dann kommen die auch ins Archiv.
Aber manche Streams, wo ich, im letzten Stream war ich mir nicht so sicher,
ob ich nicht irgendwie, äh,
Mac-Adressen und sonst wie geleakt habe.
Ich meine, das ist jetzt ja nicht schlimm,
aber muss ja auch nicht unbedingt sein.
Und dann habe ich die erstmal wieder gelöscht.
Ja, so sieht's aus.
Also, wie gesagt, kann ich dir empfehlen zu flashen, weil
die Batterie hält länger,
wenn du es geflasht hast.
Du kannst den Intervall runterstellen,
das Standardintervall, wo dieses Thermostat,
äh,
alle 2,5 Sekunden meldet dieses Thermostat.
Das ist viel zu oft.
Ich habe das runtergestellt auf 10 Sekunden, das reicht dicke.
Ich meine, als würde sich die Temperatur bei mir im Bad
alle 2,5 Sekunden ändern.
Weiß ich, wie ist das bei euch im Bad?
Ja, ist da auch alle 2,5 Sekunden
immer eine andere Temperatur?
Zumindest habe ich jetzt hochgestellt auf 10 Sekunden
und wahrscheinlich kann ich es locker hochstellen auf 5 Minuten.
Und dann hält die Batterie auch eine ganze Weile.
Ja, 2 Minuten, 2 Minuten ist gut.
Vielleicht mach ich auch 5 Minuten, aber 2 Minuten ist eigentlich ganz gut.
Too hot.
Ja, zumindest, sehr nice, kriege ich jetzt alles in Home Assistant.
Und, äh,
kann mir zugucken beim, beim PepoFett sein.
Wie lange hält der denn so? Das weiß ich noch nicht.
Also, da kommt so eine ganz normale Knopfzelle rein.
Das ist so eine CR2032 Batterie, so ein Ding, das hat irgendwie 350mAh.
Äh, Milliamperestunden, irgendwie so in dem Dreh.
Das ist jetzt nicht der Wahnsinn, ne?
Du kannst das überhaupt nicht ausschalten mit der Standard-Firmware.
Sebi, du kannst das überhaupt nicht ausschalten.
Der Sensor sendet immer alle 2,5 Sekunden, ob du den fragst oder nicht.
Habt ihr ein Interview gesehen?
Ein Interview?
Ach, meinst du das?
Moment, äh.
Meinst du das?
Was?
Was hier?
Oder was für ein Interview?
Also, er hat mich ja so, so, ach ja, okay.
Er hat mich ja quasi so, so interviewt.
Eigentlich, eigentlich haben wir 20 Minuten gelabert über Ausbildung und sonst was.
Er hat ja Anwendungsentwicklung gelernt.
Ich würd's weniger Interview nennen, aber, aber ich will zwar,
es war das einzige, was es sein konnte, ja?
Es war das einzige, was es sein konnte.
Ja, das ist wurscht, äh, who cares.
Ich spiel keine Linux in, in, in, in, was in Visual Basic?
Ach, VirtualBox?
Ähm, ist eigentlich ziemlich egal, was du da vorne auswählst.
Wähl irgendein Standardding aus, Debian, Ubuntu oder sonst wie.
Das macht, macht kaum einen Unterschied.
Bei VMware kannst du auch irgendwie Generic, Kernel 5, 6 oder so auswählen.
Ja, das, das ist eigentlich ziemlich wurscht, was du da nimmst.
Wichtiger ist, was du für Hardware einstellst.
Wisst ihr eigentlich, wie pepega-Bluetooth-Zeugs auszulesen ist?
Welches N?
Oh, das ist FFZ.
Ja, das ist FFZ.
Kannst du das Ding empfehlen?
Kon...
Ich weiß nicht, was das ist.
Alter!
Was ist das für ein Preis, alter?
Was soll das überhaupt sein?
Versteh ich nicht.
Eine Fernbedienung?
Kannst du aus der...
Ne, da mach ich schon mal ein Video zu.
Sieht ein bisschen aus wie, sieht ein bisschen aus wie eine Universal-Fernbedienung, ja?
Arbeitest du eigentlich noch am Preisschamp?
Ne.
Oh, mal gucken, ob der kaputt ist.
Der geht ja manchmal kaputt.
Oh, fuck, der ist wieder kaputt.
Der geht ja alle paar Tage kaputt.
Ja.
Keck, wait.
Muss ich, muss ich nachher nochmal neu starten, treib ich mir gleich mal auf.
Also, der Preisschamp geht nicht kaputt, der Crawler geht kaputt.
Du hast deinen E-Scooter geflasht, was machst du, wenn sie dich kontrollieren?
Toss.
Anzeige ist raus.
Äh...
Ich habe, ich habe es am Anfang mit Signal A gemacht, aber jetzt ist das alles GraphQL.
GraphQL, äh, Websocket Notifications.
Das kommt schon.
Es könnte sein, dass noch die ein oder andere Signal A-Geschichte drin ist, bin ich mir
nicht mehr ganz sicher.
Äh, aber, aber das meiste auf jeden Fall ist, äh, GraphQL.
Wo kann ich Raspberry Pi günstig kaufen?
Naja, auf Amazon.
Oder, das hier ist auch gut.
Da kaufe ich öfters mal was.
Dann wurde im Stream öfters mal das da empfohlen, da habe ich aber noch nichts bestellt.
Und, äh, aber die haben, glaube ich, keinen deutschen, die haben, glaube ich, keinen deutschen
Shop mehr.
Also, ich würde wahrscheinlich, also, wenn ich mir einen kaufen würde, würde ich das
mal hier vergleichen.
Und mal ganz im Ernst, ich glaube, du fährst mit Amazon gar nicht so, so schlecht.
Lass uns doch mal vergleichen.
Das ist ein Pi 4, 2G.
Was kostet der auf Amazon?
4, 2, G.
Ah, den gibt es da gerade gar nicht.
Soll ich mich veräppeln?
Warum soll ich das doppelt dafür ausgeben?
Keck, wait.
Ja, wenn du nicht weißt, was du mit dem machen sollst, dann würde ich einfach sagen, dass
du es nicht willst, dann würde ich es einfach sein lassen.
Warum ist das so teuer?
Was ist das?
Äh, was ist mit VMware?
Ähm, nee, geht, geht.
Du musst einfach bei einem Keyshop oder bei einer Software-Resale-Seite deiner Wahl gucken.
Da bekommst du die Lizenz schon für 25 Euro.
Da wäre ich mir nicht so sicher, die sind ja nicht blöd.
Genau, also in VMware habe ich beispielsweise das hier.
Guck, das hier.
Mein Linux-VM, also mein Linux-Desktop läuft hier in der VM.
Ich habe Windows als Host.
Und ich kann Windows-Desktop-Wechsels in die Linux-VM rein oder so.
Und dann habe ich hier nochmal extra Desktop.
Ich habe quasi virtuelle Desktops in virtuellen Desktops.
Das ist absolut Next-Level-Fivehead-Kram.
Das machen nur High-IQ-Leute.
Und das geht auch nur, weil der Chat immer so viel subscribt.
Weil ihr wisst ja, für jeden Sub.
Gibt es einen IQ-Punkt mehr für den gesamten Chat.
Und für mich.
Weil bei mir bin ich mir da nicht so sicher.
Any Primers, die gerade dabei sind.
IQ++, ja.
Also ganz ehrlich, wenn dir nichts einfällt, lass es.
Das hat keinen Sinn.
Das hat im Prinzip keinen Sinn, sich da sinnloses Hardware zu kaufen und dann die üblichen Verdächtigen zu machen.
Das sind halt so die Standard-Dinger.
Die finde ich jetzt auch nur, sagen wir mal, begrenzt sinnvoll.
Wenn man da kein richtiges Anwendungsgebiet hat.
Das ist ganz nice.
Aber braucht man eigentlich nicht, wenn man hauptsächlich am Desktop unterwegs ist.
VPN, falls man es braucht, ja.
NAS würde ich halt auch nicht auf dem Raspberry Pi machen.
Viele kann man machen, aber der Raspberry Pi ist kein gutes Board für ein ordentliches NAS.
Home Assistant oder Heimautomatisierung ist auf jeden Fall eine coole Sache, die man mit dem Raspberry Pi machen kann.
Aber wenn man da keinen Anwendungszweck für hat, dann lohnt es sich eigentlich auch nicht.
Ich glaube, er wollte Hub schreiben, nicht UB.
Ja, ja, wir haben noch jede Menge.
Guck mal da, flup.
Jede Menge Zeug.
Nee, nee, NAS, also es geht, aber sonderlich gut ist ein NAS auf Raspberry Pi nicht.
Tja, wie noch kein Kredit aufgenommen für Twitch-Subs.
Weil ich frage mich, wie die ganzen Pool-Streamer, Top-Donator das machen.
Die verschulden sich sicherlich dafür.
Warum auch immer.
Da gab es doch den Typ...
Da gab es doch diesen Typ, der bei Nin... Was bei Ninja?
Einer der Ninja-Top-Donator, wo rausgekommen ist, dass der, ähm, mit der...
Dass der dann irgendwann arbeitslos geworden ist und quasi sein ganzes Erspartes, äh, und ich glaube sogar inklusive Haus und so alles rausgehauen hat für Streamer-Donation.
Dass er auf Twitch, ich habe vergessen, wie dieser Dude heißt.
Ähm...
Dass er auf...
Dass es aussieht, als ist er voll die große Ninja.
Das ist eine super Nummer.
Der war nicht nur bei Ninja, äh, vorne mit dabei mit Donation.
Also, der hat auch...
Der hat auch bei...
Bei, äh, Grill-Streamer und so alles fett donatet.
Wie hieß der denn?
ZNinjaDonator...
Äh...
GoFundMe...
Donator...
Hier, das da.
Wobei, ob das jetzt...
Ob das jetzt so eine...
So eine seriöse Quelle ist, sei mal dahingestellt.
Aber der Typ...
Ja...
AC Royale.
So, und der Typ ist...
So, der Typ hat, ähm...
Der hat, der hat so viel donatet...
Nee, nee, das ist kein super reicher aus...
Achso, der, äh...
Ja, es gibt, es gibt einige ultra...
Massive-Geld-Typen, die, die übelst donaten auf Twitch.
Aber das hier ist halt hart, ne?
Der hat so viel donatet, dass er selbst pleite ist.
Der hatte quasi...
Weiß nicht...
Donationsucht oder so.
Äh, by the way, ich hab damit keine Probleme, wenn einer von euch Donationsucht hat.
Also...
Äh...
Bits und, äh...
Ich hab auch unten einen PayPal-Überweisungs-Link, ist überhaupt kein Problem.
Können wir machen.
Immer rein, genau immer rein.
Stonks, Alter.
Übrigens, wo wir gerade beim Thema Stonks sind...
Nicht, dass du...
Ich, ich muss immer mehr Steuern bezahlen, wenn ich was verdiene.
Aber nicht mehr Steuersatz, glücklicherweise.
Guck mal hier.
Ich hab jetzt...
Weiß gar nicht, ob man das hier sieht.
Ja, man sieht's hier nicht richtig.
Also, ich hab zum ersten Mal in meinem Leben...
284k Subscriber.
Oh, was sagt Hetzner?
Stimmt, da war heute Montag.
Ich guck mal rein.
Ich hab heute noch gar nicht geguckt.
Äh, ich mein, ich hab seit irgendwie 8 Jahren 200k oder so.
Einfach weil ich...
Weil ich nix...
Leko, jetzt nicht übertreiben hier.
Das war doch ein Witz, weißt du doch.
50 Cent, Alter.
50 Billiarden Euro am Start.
Zeig mal her.
Leko, dankeschön für die massive...
Für die massive, huge Bits.
Was haben wir denn?
50, 100, 200, 300, 400, 450.
Also, 5 Euro ungefähr.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie viel ich anteilmäßig bezahlen muss.
An Bits.
Krieg ich Bits?
Krieg ich Bits komplett?
Ich weiß es ehrlich gesagt gar nicht.
Ihre Bestellung wurde verschickt.
Nutzen Sie jetzt...
Okay, Moment.
Da muss ich mal kurz...
Ne, wobei.
Guck mal, guck mal später.
Keck, wait.
Äh...
Kooperation sein, vor allem mit Hetzner.
Oh, die haben geantwortet.
Poggers.
Okay, okay, okay.
Muss ich mal...
Ich muss mal kurz gucken.
Ich muss mal kurz gucken, was die geantwortet haben.
Ähm...
Ah, nice, nice, nice.
Bald gibt's...
Excellent Hetzner...
Hetzner Placement.
Nice.
Ach, und NordVPN ist auch wieder am Start.
Na, die dürfen natürlich nicht fehlen bei sowas.
Also, Leute.
Easy.
Bald gibt's...
Bald...
Ich hab mich mit...
Ich hab mit...
Mit Ihnen ein bisschen Gedanken gemacht.
Nein, nein.
Mit NordVPN mach ich nix.
Lull.
Die Leute, die sind nur am Start in E-Mails.
Ich mach doch...
Ich mach doch kein NordVPN-Video.
Außer, die bezahlen richtig fett Kohle.
Da mach ich ein NordVPN-Video, Alter.
Ähm...
Ja, weil ich hab mit denen...
Ich hab mit denen abgesprochen.
Man könnte ja so ne Werbung machen, wie es der Bauer gemacht hat.
Also...
Äh...
Ne?
Also einfach am Anfang...
Man macht sein Intro fürs Video.
Und dann macht man einfach so 20...
20 Sekunden...
Ähm...
Äh...
Dieses Video ist gesponsert von Hetzner, euer Cloud-Anbieter.
Bla, bla, bla, bla, bla.
Und...
Äh...
Dann gibt's Big Stonks.
Für alle Beteiligten.
Zumal...
Ähm...
Ich hab...
Zumal...
Das Witzige ist, dass ich tatsächlich...
Dass ich tatsächlich...
Ja, auch überzeugt von der Sache bin.
Dementsprechend kann ich auch tatsächlich sagen, dass das meiner Meinung nach zumindest...
Also in Deutschland definitiv der beste Cloud-Anbieter ist, was Preis-Leistung angeht.
Ich sag nicht, dass es der ultimative beste...
Äh...
Ne?
Cloud-Anbieter ever ist.
Aber zumindest preis-leistungsmäßig ist er in Deutschland definitiv der beste.
Für mich international auch.
Ähm...
Weil...
Du kriegst für die Hälfte von DigitalOcean kriegst du ne...
Kriegst du da ne Kiste.
Und letztendlich...
Was juckt's mich denn?
Was juckt's mich denn, ob das Desktop-Hardware ist oder nicht?
Das ist mir doch scheißegal, solange das ordentlich, ordentlich, äh, Rechenleistungen für...
Und RAM für das Geld gibt.
Ob da jetzt Server-Hardware drunter ist oder nicht, ist mir doch vollkommen egal.
Letztendlich sind es trotzdem...
Sind es eh irgendwelche KVM-VMs oder sonst was.
Was weiß...
Was...
Was juckt mich, ob das ne Server-CPU ist oder ne Desktop-CPU, macht überhaupt keinen
Unterschied.
So.
Ich wollte euch zeigen, das ist der, der sich Pleite donatet hat.
Ähm...
Was hältst du vom Elektrotechnik-Studium?
Wisst ihr, was das Geile ist?
Ich mach mittlerweile schon so lang Videos, dass ich zu fast jedem Video schon mal ne...
Dass ich zu fast jedem Thema schon mal ein Video gemacht hab.
Elektrotechnik-Core haben wir es glaub ich genannt.
Nein.
Elektrotechnik.
Ich hab nen Video...
Ich glaub mit dem Nilsson hab ich das gemacht.
Ich hab nen Video ma...
Gemacht, äh...
Mit nem Elektrotechniker.
Äh...
Nicht...
Nicht Kieler Junge.
Ähm...
Ich hab nen Video gemacht mit einem, der...
Der Elektrotechnik studiert.
Und...
Ich müsste das jetzt bloß noch finden.
Hier.
Das Elektrotechnikor-Studium, alter.
Von 2014.
Ich glaub, da hat sich nicht allzu viel geändert.
Sarex, wie hast du denn das so schnell gefunden?
Ich dachte ja schon immer, ich bin relativ schnell im googeln.
Aber der Chat ist wieder...
Massive.
Ha!
Ich hab schon mal Bam...
Hab ich Bam gesagt im Video?
Hahaha.
Wahrscheinlich hab ich Bam gesagt.
Nice.
In your face, alter.
Hier gibt's heute gibt's nix Großartiges zu sehen.
Nee, nee.
Das ist doch...
Wenn sogar der Chat meint, das ist ein zukunftssicherer Job, dann ist das definitiv...
Weil wir wissen ja, der Chat hat bei sowas prinzipiell immer recht.
Also...
Ich weiß nicht, wie es euch geht.
Fällt euch ne Gelegenheit ein, wo der Chat mal nicht recht hatte?
Ja.
brainigere Chats sehen wollt, müsst ihr euch Pool-Streams
angucken.
Leute, ich hab mal ne ernst gemeinte
Frage. Jetzt wirklich.
Ähm,
was versprechen sich die Leute davon,
die fett donaten
für Pool-Streams?
In Pool-Streams.
Weil ich mein, ob die jetzt meinen Namen sich
auf den Oberschenkel schreibt oder nicht, dafür
donate ich ja nicht, oder? Also das kann's
ja eigentlich nicht sein. Also weil,
was juckt's mich?
Das kann, das, das kann
doch eigentlich nur, ähm,
sag mal so, Aufmerksamkeit
im Stream sein, dass die Leute sagen,
ah, Alter, guck mal, der hat donatet.
Oder meint
ihr, es gibt wirklich, meint
ihr, es gibt wirklich Leute,
die donaten?
Also das glaub ich, also was heißt, was die, die
Frage, die Frage ist falsch gestellt. Ich glaube,
dass es Leute gibt, die donaten.
Also mal von den Aufmerksamkeitsleuten,
die das für Publicity auf Twitch
und sich geil fühlen, weil so viele sehen, mal abgesehen.
Ich glaube, es gibt wirklich
Leute, die donaten
Grill-Streamer, weil sie denken, sie haben
damit dann eine Chance bei denen.
Kann ich mir echt vorstellen.
Also, wohlgemerkt,
wohlgemerkt, ich rede jetzt hier nicht, ich rede hier von
von Pool- und Bootcamp-Streams,
ja, jetzt nicht von Mädels, die
normale Sachen streamen, das ist, da
sag ich ja nix gegen.
Das sind mehr als
zu nix, glaub ich auch, ja.
Da, Phil, dankeschön für den
Prime-Sub.
Die juckt das nie.
Die juckt das Geld, aber doch nicht
der Typ, der dahinter steht und donatet.
Ganz ehrlich, würde mich an der Stelle,
würde mich an Bootcamp-Streamer-Stelle auch nicht interessieren.
Ich versteh's nicht.
Vor allem, was ich auch nicht kapier, ist,
also, wenn die Leute
da irgendwelche
Salami-Absichten haben
in diesen Streams,
das versteh ich gar nicht, ehrlich gesagt,
weil, dafür gibt's
so viele Dinger,
wo quasi,
teilweise die gleichen Mädels, die auf Twitch Pool-Stream machen,
dann quasi zu anderen Uhrzeiten
dort, äh, richtig
streamen, ja, und
dann sollen die Leute einfach da donaten.
Egal, egal,
ich muss es, ich, ich,
ich muss das nicht verstehen.
Ich will's auch nicht, ich will's eigentlich gar nicht so genau verstehen, ja.
Ja, wahrscheinlich,
wahrscheinlich, ich weiß nicht.
Komisch.
Macht euch der Bitcoin-Kurs,
macht so der Bitcoin-Kurs,
Ausbildung,
oder Studium mit 26, das,
was willst du denn machen,
die Ex-View, was, was würdest du machen, mal unabhängig davon,
von deinem Alter, so, wonach ist es dir denn?
Oh.
Moment.
Ah.
Exquisite.
Quatsch. Passt.
Das geht, ja, du hast recht,
es gibt, stimmt, weil die gucken komisch, aber ist kein Problem.
Hat auch seine Vorteile.
Äh.
Woan hat er denn geschrieben?
Moment.
Äh.
Ex-View.
Hat er schon was geantwortet?
Nee.
Wie gesagt, wir hatten in der Berufsschule auch Leute, die, die, die älter sind, das ist, das ist kein Problem.
Ich, es kann sein, ich bin mir da nicht sicher, es kann sein,
dass, wenn du nicht mehr schulpflichtig bist, dass du dich irgendwie, glaub, auch sogar von der Berufsschule irgendwie befreien lassen kannst, oder so.
Ich bin hingegangen, obwohl ich auch schon über 21 war.
Ich mein, ich war, lass mal überlegen, Leute.
Ich bin hingegangen, obwohl ich auch schon über 21 war, ich mein, ich war, lass mal überlegen, Leute.
Ich war, glaub ich, auch...
Ich mein, ich hab ja vorher noch diese, noch, noch, äh, kaufmännischen Kram versucht zu machen, wo ich heute Abneigung fürs Leben zu hab, deswegen.
Ähm.
Also ich bin 1984 geboren. Was war 2007?
Was war 2007?
Wie alt war ich 2007, Leute? Big Brain.
2000 war ich 16.
Dann war ich 23, hä?
Ja.
Gut, dann siehste.
Dann war ich in der Ausbildung mit 23.
Ja, ja, Leute.
Wir brauchen noch Wubboomer.
Ist der Chainlord da?
Wobei, wir haben, wir haben, wir haben Wubboomer, wir haben Wubold, es reicht.
Also ich kann mich dran erinnern,
ich hab meinen Vertrag unterschrieben, meinen Ausbildungsvertrag, bevor es das iPhone gab.
Das weiß ich noch.
Also, also,
also, ich kann mich noch dran erinnern,
als ich in der Ausbildung war, als das iPhone rausgekommen ist, deswegen weiß ich, dass ich mein,
dass ich definitiv angefangen hab, bevor das iPhone rausgekommen ist und, äh, dass ich auch, äh, unterschrieben hab, das Jahr davor, dann, also, sprich, ähm,
ich, ich weiß noch genau, wo die Leute rumgeflitzt sind bei uns wegen iPhone und wollten, wollten gleich gucken, ob jemand eins hat und so, ja.
Was hattest du,
was hattest du zu der Zeit, äh, ich hatte ein, wartet mal, das hatte ich übrigens jahrelang noch, ich, ich, ich, ich war ja richtig, richtig, richtig Boomer-mäßig, ich hatte ja, ich hatte ja, glaube ich, bis,
bis 2000, keine Ahnung, bis 2010 oder so, ich hatte ja erst ein Smartphone ab 2010, glaube, oder sowas, ich war da richtig langsam, ich hatte vorher irgendwie so ein komisches Siemens A, äh, frag mich nicht, Handy, so ein, so ein Teil hier, so ein blaues, Alter,
so ein Teil hatte ich, genau, der Kram, der hatte immerhin Snake drauf, ja.
Das ist richtig, ey, das ist aber gar nicht so groß gewesen, das, Moment, das kann man kaufen, wait a minute, Moment, das kann man kaufen, wow, 117 Euro, Alter, meine Güte, ist ja, äh, äh, äh, äh, Moment, das ist was anderes, okay, nee, das gibt's, das gibt's nicht mehr,
gibt's nicht mehr, das hätte mich jetzt auch echt gewundert, wenn es so ein Crap noch gäbe, man kann es auf D-Tronic kaufen, was auch immer das ist,
ja, ich, ich muss sagen, ich habe mich nie für Handys interessiert, ich habe mich nie für Handys interessiert, mein Interesse kam dann wirklich erst, als es Smartphone gab an der ganzen Geschichte und ich habe mich auch lange nicht für Smartphones großartig interessiert, ich interessiere mich heute noch immer noch nicht großartig für Smartphones, da gibt's aber auch, ehrlich gesagt, gar nicht so viel, worum man sich dafür interessieren kann,
ähm, das hat dann erst so ein bisschen angefangen, als ich, äh, ein iPhone, was war denn das?
Okay.
iphone history was kam denn da raus in welcher reihenfolge in welcher reihenfolge was ich
aktuell habe ich habe ein iphone xr und noch einen 6 iphone 6 aber das verwende ich dann
mal hallo in welcher reihenfolge kam der kram dann raus iphone 1 iphone 2 ich weiß es gar
nicht mehr jetzt eine gute history ja drei ja hier das hatte ich das hatte ich ich glaube ich
hatte ich glaube ich hatte den 4s war das zweite was ich hatte ein 4s war das zweite dann hatte
ich glaube ich so eins oder so eins oder ich weiß nicht mehr ich habe mir das ja ich habe das ja von
der firma damals gekriegt als handy was
man auch privat verwenden darf und sonst hätte ich mir wahrscheinlich gar keins gekauft ich war
damals schon zu zu boomer für smartphone ja gut heute hast du mit fünf schon smartphone ja was
kam jetzt hier eigentlich raus mit mit studium ich habe ich habe mit dem wombo eins zum mathe
studium gemacht das ist noch gar nicht so lange her hattest du schon siri ich habe heute noch
nicht mal siri ich glaube das erste iphone was ich hatte hatte
ich glaube das erste iphone was ich hatte hatte das erste iphone was ich hatte hatte
noch kein siri okay er hat nicht mehr darauf geantwortet ja gut dann doch hier eigentlich
studium aber ich sollte endlich mal richtig arbeiten geht na gut kommt drauf an ob die
kohle langt oder nicht also in der regel wenn man es irgendwie wenn es irgendwie machbar ist
würde ich würde ich ganz ehrlich sagen man sollte das machen wo man am meisten bock drauf hat wenn
du dir das zutraut und das ist was du machen willst du solltest dich im vorfeld zumindest
ein bisschen darüber informieren weil ich glaube dass gerade was informatik studium angeht
viele leute da technikstellt erwarten und mit hardware computer kam hat das ganze gar nichts
zu tun und das ist halt ist halt sehr viel matte und theoretische sachen es sei denn man macht so
komische sachen wie wirtschaftsinformatik aber da ist wirtschaft dabei hätte ich persönlich keinen
bock drauf aber das muss ja jeder selbst wissen was beantwortet die frage von quenfe ich glaube es geht
mehr oder weniger
ok muss runter scrollen ich bin ja das video ist übelst gut angekommen welche welche frage
ich beantworten mit ingenieuren informatik hat nichts zu tun ich sehe hier nichts beantworten
soll exquisite so grab handy grab handy genau was ich eigentlich ursprünglich sagen wollte ist vielleicht schaffe ich dieses jahr
weg durch ich diesem video
jetzt habter
hier
görsch
serves
das ist redaktion
indung
kers
أنا
gerade
mehr
flo
ja
und
sage complaining
Qing
die stellenanzeigen videos doch doch doch meine abo zahl hat sich verändert die letzten jahre
ging die ja eher runter weil ich nichts gemacht habe ich habe aktuell so viele abos wie noch nie
vorher also ich habe jetzt quasi alles wieder aufgeholt was ich verloren hat die letzten sechs
jahre meine firma war einer stellenanzeige kam aber gut weg ist doch nice kann ja auch mal alles
kacke sein nee das ist nicht sinnlos das ist sinnlos ich brauche richtige abos außerdem ist
es verboten waren trotzdem welche aber das ist ja sinnlos du hast wegen du hast wegen dem
stellenanzeigen video bei der bahn angefangen okay die bahn ist eine video nicht so gut weg
gekommen was ich übrigens lustig fand die die einen haben sogar darauf geantwortet
moment wo sind die denn da haben welche darauf geantwortet haben wir das wieder gelöscht haben
wir das wieder gelöscht die hatten drauf geantwortet
die die typen die ich als erstes gezeigt hatte auch keine schlechte keine keine
schlechte antwort ja haben die das gelöscht twitter die haben auch auf twitter die haben
überall geantwortet auf youtube auf twitter moment ist das muss ich jetzt mal überprüfen
ob die das gelöscht haben das finde ich ja relativ schnell das war irgendwann im dezember
bringt sie katz steht neuerdings voll auf man stinkt das hemd ich weiß auch nicht warum
auf twitter gibt gibt gas hier da ist es eine das die zweite die zweite ja ja das war im dezember
ja die haben das gelöscht oder alle da sind sie warum wurde das ausgeblendet ich habe das nicht
ausgeblendet ich habe das sogar gelangt ich bin mir ziemlich sicher dass die hier geantwortet
haben beide way daran sieht man mal wieder soll ich euch mal was sagen ich muss so übelst rum rage ist
ist der ist absolut cancer auf webseiten so eine scheiße warum macht jede website endless scroll so
eine kacke sie sollen entweder die sollen vielleicht mal also wenn die endlos kohl machen also soll
sich ein search balken hier oben einbauen oder sowas ach da ist es doch hier da guck hier also
sie haben es gleich darauf geantwortet aber ohne scheiß endlich scroll ist absoluter grab ich weiß
gar nicht wozu gibt es überhaupt endlos kohl ich meine guckte mal das video hat 700 comments
Meint YouTube ernsthaft
700 Comments schafften aktuelle Rechner
Nicht zu laden auf einer Seite oder was
Was ist denn die Alternative
Naja einfach die Sachen untereinander darstellen
Fertig
Einfach komplett laden
Ist doch kein Problem
Kannst du machen
Alternativ machst du einfach verschiedene Seiten
Die du durchklicken kannst
Also so wie früher
Seite 1, Seite 2, Seite 3
Das kann man auch machen
Da kann man sich zumindest merken auf welcher Seite irgendwas war
Oh da gibt es ein Addon zu
Zeig mal
Suche Kommentare auf YouTube
Was ist das für ein Name für den Addon
Der Eugene Guba
Hat das gemacht
YouTube Comment Search
Okay wollen wir das mal ausprobieren
Das probieren wir jetzt mal aus
Easy
YouTube Comment Search für Chrome verfügbar
Ah Moment
Chrome
Exquisite Chrome
Zack
Hier machen wir mal auf im Chrome
Und jetzt
Das im Chrome
Was
Eieiei erschreckt mich nicht so
Okay hinzufügen
Add
Erstmal Virus einfangen
Nein nein Max halt die Klappe
So wo ist das Addon hin
Hier
Open Video on YouTube
Find the
Was
YCS
Extension
Current Video
Ach hier
Ah guck mal da
Okay
Ah funktioniert nicht
Ah muss man erstmal Load sagen
Ich mein das kann doch nicht sein
Dass man so eine
Crap überhaupt braucht dafür
Das es funktioniert äh
Chat gibt es da ein Chat
Okay die Sache funktioniert
Das ist ein gutes Addon
Aber das ist echt mal der Witz oder
Das ist so Crap
Das man nicht einfach mal
Ach man kann da oben auch Load All klicken
Es ist so Fail einfach nur das es diese Endless Scroll Geschichte gibt
Und wisst ihr was auch übelst Fail ist
Ähm
Das diese Sortierfunktion
Die ist maximal Useless
Ich mein Most Popular lasse ich mir noch gefallen
News lasse ich mir auch gefallen
Oldes ist auch okay
Aber warum kann ich nicht nach Monaten oder Jahr sortieren
Vielleicht guck mal
Ich mein
Vielleicht weiß jemand
Ah der Max da hat doch mal als ich die Ausbildung angefangen hab
Ungefähr ein Video gemacht
Das müsste 2016 sein
Warum gibt es kein Knopf einfach 2016
Oder
Warum gibt es hier unten nicht wenigstens was
Ich mein guckt euch das mal an
Wenn ich ein Video suche muss ich jetzt erstmal
Eine halbe Stunde dieses
Dieses fucking Endless Scroll Ding nach unten scrollen
Ich weiß die Technologie ist einfach noch nicht da dafür
Die Technologie ist einfach noch nicht da
Die ging zwar vor
Vor 15 Jahren schon aber
Das geht nicht
So jetzt habe ich erstmal alle Videos geladen
Und jetzt kann ich hier irgendwie sagen
Elektrotechnik
Zumal sie es ja auch noch scheiße machen
Sie machen es ja auch noch scheiße
Sie lassen ja auch noch alles im Buffer drin
Noch viel schlimmer sind die Seiten
Also was heißt sie machen scheiße nein nein
Sie machen es weniger scheiße
Das habe ich versprochen
Es gibt nämlich auch Seiten
Die entladen das
Die machen das alles mit JavaScript
Also sprich
Wenn du weiter scrollst
Dann sind die gar nicht mehr auf der Seite
Diese Dinger
Dann kannst du das gar nicht machen
Eine der schlimmsten Sachen ist hier
Discourse oder wie dieses Ding heißt
Äh
Comments
Das ist das ist das ist echt
Das hier genau
Das ist auch so
So richtiger
Webdesign Cancer Shit alter
Guck mal
Du kannst jetzt hier
Du kannst hier nix suchen drin
Du kannst nix suchen
Weil wenn du scrollst
Wenn die
Wenn du scrollst
Entladen die oberen Sachen
Guck das sieht so aus
Das sieht so aus
Als scrollst du die Seite
Aber wenn du seht ihr es
Wenn ich schnell scrolle
Seht ihr
Die laden per JavaScript im Hintergrund
Die Comments nach
Je nachdem wo ich am scrollen bin
Die sind nicht drin
Das heißt wenn ich hier unten
Gucken wir mal hier unten
Unten Kommentar
So hier
Linking to existing topics
Jetzt gehe ich hoch
Suche
Und dann
Und ich finde es nicht
Mach das mal Mobile
Knallst mal eben das Datenvolumen weg
Tja
Gäb es nur im Jahr 2021
Technologien mit denen man feststellen kann
Ob einer Mobile oder mit dem Desktop Browser darauf zugreift
Die Technologie ist einfach noch nicht da
Technologie existiert noch nicht
Jetzt mal Spaß bei Seite
Du
Feststellen ob es Mobile ist
Beziehungsweise anhand des
Der Bildschirm Auflösung
Ist es überhaupt kein Problem
Also du kannst komplett
Komplett ohne Probleme feststellen
Mit welchem Bildschirm da einer draufgehen
Ob es Mobile ist
So
Und wisst ihr was das Allerschlimmste an dieser Plattform ist
Wenn ihr hier drinnen seid und drückt Steuerung F
Dann würde man eigentlich erwarten
Search Dialog kommt
Aber nein
Die haben Steuerung F überschrieben
Das Webdesign 2021 ist teilweise so
Abgrundtiefer Müll
Ey das ist der Wahnsinn
Aha
Was
Ja gut
So ungefähr
So ungefähr hat sich die Stellenanzeige auch gelesen
Als hat das einer geschrieben der da keinen Plan von hat
Aber die Antwort fand ich schon nett
Also die machen durchaus den Eindruck als könnte man da arbeiten
Die Stellenanzeige war halt ein bisschen Fail
So jetzt habe ich genug aufgelegt
Aber ey ohne Scheiß Webdesign ist schlimm
Es ist mittlerweile echt schlimm geworden
Ja den kenne ich
Guck ich nur
Ich gucke
Ich gucke es ehrlich gesagt nur relativ selten
Weil
Der macht ja
Der macht ja mittlerweile auch relativ viele so Story Videos
Ne
Man könnte fast sagen so ein bisschen wie ich
Wo er so von seinem Leben erzählt
Nur das ich bei ihm manchmal das Gefühl habe
Der Kerl hat auch schon irgendwie alles mal erlebt
Und sicherlich
Naja
Auch durchaus ausgeschmückt
Ja
Der wird auf YouTube gebannt
Warum sollte der gebannt werden auf YouTube?
Der macht doch nichts
Der macht doch nichts schlimmes
Ja genau das ist natürlich wichtiger als das man ordentlich die Kommentare durchsuchen kann
Verstehe
Was?
Echt was hat er denn gemacht?
Alter was ist das für eine
Was zum Teufel ist das für eine Website
Die hat er absichtlich so schlecht gemacht oder?
Google is deleting
Was ist
I now cannot post
Der hat einfach einen Strike gekriegt
Ja gut bestimmt wegen Hacker Content
Bestimmt wegen Hacker Content
Was hältst du von den Chellys?
Ja POG riecht gut
Der macht Technik Videos auf
Oder IT Videos auf YouTube
Ja gut
Die werden den glaube ich nicht bannen
Da hat man bei Semper Video gesehen
Sobald der Aufschrei so groß ist
Dass ein Mensch sich das ganze anguckt
Ist das immer
Ist das immer wieder vom Tisch
So schon
Da ist schon was dran
Ich wusste gar nicht was da drin ist
Ist schon was dran
Ich muss sagen eines der cringigsten Sachen ist
Das habe ich schon mal im Stream erzählt
Von einem
Also ihr wisst
Wenn ich den Editor verwendet
Dann im Prinzip eigentlich
Auf der Konsole auch nur wim
Aber trotzdem ich finde
Manche sehen das deutlich zu religiös
Und zwar
Habe ich mal
einen Konferenztalk gesehen
Von einem
Der auch auf einer Rubiconferenz
Von so einem Hardcore-Wimmer.
Der hat auch immer den Joke gemacht, wenn er sich verschrieben hat in der Präsentation.
I'm wimming too hard.
Ich weiß nicht, das war nach dem zweiten Mal nicht mehr lustig, aber...
Naja, und das war auf einer Ruby-Konferenz und der Typ, der war eh komisch, das war mega cringe.
Der hat gesagt, okay, er erzählt uns jetzt mal was über guten Ruby-Code.
Und dann meinte der Typ ernsthaft in seinem Konferenztalk,
ja, also Leute, mal eine Frage an euch, also hat er so ins Publikum gefragt,
auf diesem Talk hat er so ins Publikum gefragt,
was meint ihr, ab wann ist für mich eine Funktion zu lang?
Ab wann habe ich so das Gefühl, da, das ist zu viel?
Und ich dachte mir so, ja gut, was wird der jetzt erzählen, 10 Zeilen, 15 Zeilen,
ich meine, das ist immerhin Ruby, da kannst du alles relativ kurz und knackig machen.
Und er meinte, ohne Scheiß,
ähm,
ab der ersten Zeit,
also quasi, wenn eine Methode oder eine Funktion länger als eine Zeile ist, ist sie zu lang.
Wie stelle ich mir die Programme von dem Dude vor?
Da findest du noch gar nichts mehr.
Der macht, der versucht dann irgendeine Funktionalität einzubauen.
Ist kein Witz, war ein Ruby-Talk.
Ruby, Wim, aber ich guck mal, ob ich das mal finde.
Warte mal, das muss ich jetzt mal schnell suchen.
Ähm, Wim, Ruby, Talk.
Ähm, äh,
OneLinesCodeSmell, ich find das bestimmt nicht mehr.
YouTube, OneLineConference, das Arr-Camp, ne.
Okay, ne, keine, keine Ahnung.
Ne, der hat das ernst gemeint, der hat das wirklich ernst gemeint.
Klar, von dem hat doch jeder schon was gehört.
Ähm, kann ich nichts zu sagen, ich hab nur die Einser.
Aber das ist echt der Witz.
Ich mein, hallo.
Geile Zeile.
Das heißt, wenn du irgendeine Funktionalität implementieren willst,
brauchst du erstmal, ähm,
insgesamt dann
10 mal so viele Zeilen,
weil du um alles,
so was bescheuert das, Alter.
Ja.
Hab ich, ich hab zwei.
Ich hab die Gosund.
Leute, ich, ich weiß, ich weiß, es ist Painter,
ich muss den Standard-Talk wieder bringen.
Wie nennt man den Hersteller?
Gosund nach Corona?
Gosund, ha, lull, huge Choke.
Ich weiß, ich weiß, ich weiß, es ist Painz, Painz-Champ, Painz-Champ, richtiger Painz-Champ.
Ähm, ich hab einmal die da.
Die da.
Die hab ich unten geflasht, in der, in der, äh, in der Küche.
Konnte man, haben wir im Stream geflasht, das sind die, die ich kaputtgebrochen hab an der einen Seite.
Im Stream, und dann hab ich die SP-112 mit USB.
Die haben wir erst letztens im Stream geflasht.
Und, sie funktionieren auch wunderbar.
Mit Custom-Firmware, ja.
Aber es ist immer, es ist immer echt schwierig zu, rauszufinden, was man, was man flashen kann und was nicht.
Weißt du, ob was Neues bezüglich den eBay-Windows-Keys, ne, keine Ahnung, aber Windows-Keys sind so billig,
und du brauchst ja theoretisch gar keinen, ich würd das nicht auf eBay kaufen.
Ja, ja, ohne Scheiß, genauso stell ich mir das auch vor.
Total, totaler Fail.
Das ist genauso fernab der Realität.
Genauso, wie, ähm, die Leute denken, dass Programmieren so aussieht.
Moment, Moment.
Mit Comments, by the way, mit Comments.
Das ist, glaub ich, übrigens, äh, Linux, Linux-Kernel-Source.
Sekunde, richtige Hacker-Mood.
Aha, mhm, ja, ja.
Ja, ich hab's gleich, ich hab's gleich, ah, yes, excellent, excellent.
Also, beides äh, äußerst realitätsnah, ja.
Also, wer da echt nah dran ist, ist dieser, ist, ist dieser eine Competitive-Programmer,
der, äh, mit, mit, mit, mit, mit GWIM unter Windows am Start ist.
Ähm, dieser Typ, der eine Asiade, der da, der da, Alter, der Typ, das, das ist nicht normal, ey.
Das ist nicht, das ist nicht normal.
Leute, GWIM unter Windows, Alter, ihr müsst mal, ihr müsst mal zugucken, wie der das, wie der den Code auskackt, quasi nur.
Passt mal auf, ey.
What the fuck?
Das ist so krass, Alter.
Das ist richtige Hacker, man, ey.
Und, und, übrigens, übrigens, der tippt nicht einfach nur sinnlose Sachen, der löst damit echte Aufgaben.
Also, ich könnte auch so schnell schreiben und wahrscheinlich, und wahrscheinlich könnte ich sogar irgendwas so schnell schreiben, was dann am Ende kompiliert, aber nie, nie im Leben irgendwas Sinnvolles.
Ja, gut, die ganzen Competitive-Programmer stehen auf C++.
Die Aufgaben sind nicht so super schwierig, aber das, die, die Schwierigkeit macht, macht die Menge und, ähm, die Geschwindigkeit.
Also, ich glaube, die Aufgaben würden wir mehr oder weniger auch hinbekommen, alle, aber halt nicht in der Geschwindigkeit.
Und, und vielleicht nicht unbedingt in C++.
Der, der Typ ist echt heftig drauf.
Vor allem, ich finde die Kombination auch geil.
Also, GWIM unter Windows, aber nur plain Syntax-Highlighting.
Sonst nix.
Was zum Teufel macht denn Syncris...
Äh, ich würde mal vermuten, dass, also, das ist C++, ich weiß nicht, ich würde mal versuchen, dass es so was wie ein Flush oder so, dass er die Sachen auch rausschreibt.
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
By the way, kann man da nicht eigentlich cheaten?
Also, cheaten in Form von, dass man sich schon total viele vorgefertigte Sachen...
Oder muss man das Livestreamen?
Weil ansonsten baut man sich quasi schon die 50 häufigsten Probleme, die da dran kommen.
Baut man sich...
Baut man sich einfach schon was fertig zum Copy und Pasten und passt das nur noch ein bisschen an?
Das Chrome-Theme, das richtige Hackerman.
Ja.
Ja, du machst Linklist, Binary Trees, so die üblichen Dinger halt.
Ey, der Typ, der geht aber echt voll ab, also, da gibt's nix.
Der ist Poggers.
Ja, Quicksort, Mergesort, die üblichen Dinger.
Ja, klar hab ich das mitbekommen.
Äh, irgendein, irgendein, ähm, Jam, äh, ist...
Irgendein, ähm, Meme, Mime, Mime-Type, äh, Package hatte Probleme.
Ja, ja, das hab ich mitbekommen.
Das ist ein bisschen wie, wie, wie dieses Is-Odd-Is-Even-NPM-Package, was auch NPM kaputt gemacht hat.
Das stimmt wohl, ja.
Nee, da bin ich zu low brain.
Ich kann mich im Stream nicht richtig konzentrieren.
Äh, ich weiß nicht, ob das einer kennt.
Wenn, wenn man, wenn man zugeguckt bekommt und, ähm...
Ich kann mich, ich kann mich nur zu, sag ich mal mal, 80% auf, äh, sowas konzentrieren.
Im Stream.
Das reicht für die Sachen, die wir hier ohne Zeitdruck machen.
Ihr seht doch, wie lahm wir mit den einfachsten Dingern teilweise sind hier im Stream.
Was ist an G-Wim besser als Notepad++?
Es ist was komplett anderes.
Also...
Notepad++ ist halt ein stinknormaler Texteditor nach dem klassischen Texteditor-Schema mit halt ein bisschen Funktionen wie Syntax-Highlighting oder, oder irgendwelche Plugins und so.
Also im Prinzip ist Notepad++ ein klassischer Texteditor mit einem Eingabefeld.
Und du schreibst rein.
Wim hast du halt die ganzen Shortcuts und vor allem die ganzen, diese, diese Wim-Language, ne?
Also zum Beispiel, was du halt mit Wim machen kannst, um es mal ganz kurz zu zeigen, also...
Na, du machst jetzt, du hast jetzt hier irgendeine Textdatei, so.
Äh, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla.
So, du hast hier irgendeine Textdatei.
Und Wim ist halt Big Brain.
In jedem anderen, also wenn du das jetzt, wenn du das hier jetzt, ähm, also das zwischen den Anführungsstrichen, ne?
Wenn du das ändern willst...
Dann musst du bei jedem Text...
Dann musst du bei jedem Texteditor den hier machen.
Dann musst du bei jedem Texteditor hier hingehen und das löschen.
So.
Bei Wim ist das anders.
Bei Wim gehst du einfach in die, ne?
Gehst du einfach in die jeweilige Zeile, wo du hin willst.
Das kannst du auch mit Doppelpunkt, äh, Doppelpunkt 7 machen.
Und dann sagst du einfach CI Anführungszeichen und zack ist alles weg und ersetzt.
Ist halt easy, ne?
Und wenn du das Ganze noch öfters hast, äh, also...
Ups.
Warum haben wir da irgendwie, warum haben wir irgendwie andere Krempel rein?
Alter.
Mein Wim-Lack leckt voll.
So.
Was du jetzt machen kannst ist, was du jetzt machen kannst ist, du kannst, ähm, wenn du das hier alles ersetzen willst, so,
dann kannst du sagen, CI das, ich will das alles durch 1, 2, 3 ersetzen.
So, dann gehst du jetzt runter, machst einfach nur Punkt, Punkt, Punkt, Punkt, Punkt und hast alle Sachen dazwischen ersetzt.
Ja, also, das hast du halt in normalen Texteditors nicht.
Was halt schon äußerst nice ist.
Du kannst auch so Sachen machen wie, ich will jetzt alles auskommentieren.
Da sagst du hier vorne den, zack, Escape.
Ist halt, ist halt schon nice, was da alles standardmäßig drin ist.
Übrigens, wusstet ihr, dass Wim zählen kann?
Ctrl-X, Ctrl-A.
Warum auch immer Ctrl-X und Ctrl-A?
Ich hab keinen blassen Schimmer, was Ctrl-X und Ctrl-A mit Increment, Decrement zu tun hat, aber...
Ja, und beidemal, wenn ihr die Zeile unten drunter nur leicht anpassen wollt...
Oh Mist, war das nicht X?
Ne, Y, Y.
Du kannst quasi die Zeile oben drüber schreiben lassen.
Nochmal, bis zu dem Punkt, wo du es ändern willst.
Es gibt total viel, es gibt total viel Zeug in der Richtung, ja.
Ist also nice und das ist halt der große Unterschied zwischen so einem klassischen Texteditor und Wim Magic.
Ja, gibt's Wim Golf und sowas, gibt's jede Menge.
Increment, X-Crement.
Äh, naja.
Ich weiß ja nicht.
Übrigens, wenn man alles löschen will, man kann übrigens auch mit G und G, wenn man alles löschen will, ne.
Da kannst du auch, also wenn du alles markieren willst, sagst du einfach V, äh, VG.
Und wenn du D drückst, löscht er alles, aber du kannst auch einfach sagen, äh, äh, Moment, was war das jetzt?
DG?
Ist auch alles weg.
Also, es ist abgedreht, das Ding, ja.
Gibt's auch Wim für Word?
Nächste.
Mich würde es nicht wundern, wenn es ein Wim-Plugin für Word gibt.
Wie pro Office?
Ernsthaft?
Hahaha.
Und für LibreOffice, Kalk Writer.
Ach, du Scheiße.
Warum gibt's es für Word nicht?
Wow.
Ich will es für Word.
Äh, für Word gibt's anscheinend nicht.
Dazu würden die meisten Leute wohl eher sagen, das ist ja das Coole an Wim.
Ähm, ich weiß nicht, inwieweit du da schon was mit gemacht hast, aber...
Das ist ja das Coole an der Wim-Sundags, du musst dir nicht so viele Tastenkombinationen merken.
Also, es ist im Vergleich zu...
Es ist im Vergleich zu den anderen Texteditoren oder, sagen wir mal, auch sowas wie Emacs oder so,
die extrem Tastenkombinations-heavy sind, ist Wim nicht wirklich Tastenkombination-heavy.
Also, sprich, Wim hat eine eigene Editiersprache.
Also, du musst jetzt nicht zum Beispiel merken, äh, Control, Control-X-I-B ist, ähm, Change-Klammern und sowas.
Du hast bei Wim solche Sachen wie zum Beispiel, also wenn du...
Na gut, ich muss mal jetzt wieder irgendwas hinschreiben.
So, du hast, du hast da so eine Syntax, du hast zum Beispiel, machen wir hier nochmal Dinger, so.
Du hast zum Beispiel sowas wie C, wenn ich C drücke, heißt das immer Change.
Wenn ich W drücke, heißt das Word.
So, also, es fängt immer mit C an und dann gibt es zum Beispiel C-I-W ist Change in a Word, macht keinen Sinn, aber funktioniert auch.
Aber wenn ich dann mache C-I Quotes, dann changed es die Quotes innen drin.
Also, sprich, ähm...
Du musst dir diese Wim-Sprache merken, nicht wirklich die Shortcuts und die ergibt nach einer Zeit auch zumindest ansatzweise Sinn.
Wim 3D. Ja, Wim 3D haben wir hier im Stream ausprobiert zu starten, es hat leider nicht funktioniert.
Wirst du manchmal von Zuschauern erkannt? Ich wurde schon mal von...
Definitiv zwei Azubis, äh, eigentlich drei, drei Azubis erkannt, ja.
Das mag ich nicht, im Browser mag ich es nicht, weil, äh, Maus ist immer noch das Beste im Browser.
Oh!
Zu 22.14, Leute.
Ich muss ins Bett.
Zu was für einem Ding?
Da, wo das Archiv programmiert wird.
Okay, Leute.
Macht's gut.
Guck mal, kurzer Stream.
Guck mal, schnell, ob ich jemanden hosten kann.
Wartet mal, warte mal, ganz schnell.
Frasier oder so, ist der Frasier am Start?
Frasier? Frasier da?
Oh, na gut, der muss auch arbeiten.
Semper Video ist am Start.
Provider.
Ja, hosten wir das Semper Video, passt.
Exquisite.
Ich bin da aber nicht mehr, ne?
Also, ich bin dann, bin gleich weg dann.
Ich komm nicht, ich bin drüber.
Aber ihr könnt ja mal vorbeistelzen und eine Runde Wuppgasm oder was auch immer spammen.
Hat er eigentlich, hat er eigentlich Custom Emotes mittlerweile?
Aber ich glaube, Semper Video ist jemand, der wird niemals Eieiei aktivieren auf seinem Channel, oder?
Irgendwie macht er nicht so den, den, den Weep-Eindruck.
Nee, gibt's.
Gibt's nix.
Nee, natürlich nicht.
Okay, Leute, macht's gut.
Bis, bis dann.
See you.